puis en cours maurepas la revanche de la
demi-finale de la coupe davis remporté
en avril dernier par maurepas domicile
aux tirs au but
cette fois ci les deux équipes se
retrouvaient en terre gluant courtoise à
l'occasion du cinquième match du
championnat excellence au stade maurice
baquet après un début de match équilibré
les verts de maurepas ouvre le score à
la 10e minute par rodney pinault qui
évolué sous les couleurs de guyancourt
la dernière action construite comme le
coach l'a demandé quand notre ailier des
workshops dans la surface donc j'ai fait
exprès je me suis écarté de mon
défenseur pour entrer dans la surface et
imparable frappe bute s'est fait plaisir
après le but more pas déroulé s'offrent
plusieurs occasions franches repoussées
par le dernier rempart de but encore
jordan doussain auteur d'une solide
prestation on aurait pu facilement
sortir avec 3 à la mi temps mais on est
resté solide et après le but on n'a pas
su ma parole à l'europe qu'il lui
fallait pour marquer ce but là est mort
par exemple une déçue 45 retour des
vestiaires dion cours revient avec de
meilleures intentions et aurait pu
recoller au score à la 60e minute avec
le poteau trouvé par thierry
beaudemoulin le coach nous a bien bien
remonté nous a mis face à face à face
nous a parlé nous a créé dessus nous a
encouragés donc on se doit de réagir
pour une montre ou bien trop fort en
cours sous presion maurepas joue en
contre dans cette deuxième période et
obtient un penalty suite à une faute
dans la surface
alexis tissier ne tremble pas et permet
aux verts de se détacher dans cette
partie le haut pour marquer la dernière
seconde mais s'incline 2 1
au classement les verts remontent à la
cinquième place légumes courtois son 10e
la semaine prochaine il faudra gagner
encore et pourquoi pas viser les trois
premières places voire la première place
en d'art toujours la montée toujours la
montée la montée l'effectif pour on va
travailler des nouveaux genres on est
beaucoup beaucoup de nouveaux joueurs
donc on va travailler travailler
travailler un match en retard
voilà si on gagne on va travailler mais
c'est la montée toujours la montée pour
viser la montée guillaucourt devra
rattraper les points perdus à domicile
en s'imposant sur le terrain de l'équipe
de versailles dimanche prochain pour pas
de son côté recevra aubergenville le
leader du championnat excellence